my mum she's 76 she's actually really a
nice sweet person and I'm really Furious
what they're doing to her in February
Nancy's mum Patricia noticed swelling in
her eye that got worse her GP made a
referral but it took months of waiting
canceled appointments begging letters to
consultants and even their MP before she
finally had a date for a biopsy in
hospital nine months later I called her
back
um
a couple of weeks later I think it was
and they told you it is cancerous and
they've said that we need to investigate
whether it spread and we won't ever know
if they'd have seen her in a more timely
manner
whether that is going to make a
difference to the outcome I don't even
want to think about it I don't know if
they're just overwhelmed and they've
just stopped caring it's like really
kind of just broken NHS pressures have
been well documented their impact for
people of all ages across the country
beyond the physical can't drive so I've
got no Independence and I can't do
simple things like bathing the children
um you know hoovering trying to help
keep things going and tidy is really
hard I'm sorry I'm unable to take
Lisa Howard injured her knee back in
February but an operation that should
have happened within six weeks after
diagnosis has just been scheduled for
March next year it's had a huge impact
on my mental health because I feel like
I'm a strain and a drain on everybody
else and that I'm so dependent and it's
just been really difficult
waiting Less in England are at record
levels ambulance stuff amongst the
healthcare workers set to strike the
ambulance didn't come for six hours I
was lying on the floor for six hours
screaming with pain Jeanette Smith had
dislocated her hip the care she
eventually received she says was
excellent but the trauma of that weight
remains if somebody had come and just
given me pain relief during that six
hours I could have coped
you know it seems like we're accepting
this and that was the norm and it
shouldn't be and and it's not the nurses
and the ambulance man's fault it's the
um it's the government they need to sort
something out
there is anger and genuine sadness here
a sense of families let down by a Health
Service they still believe they could
depend on in their most desperate
moments
Catherine evertots see Sky News